[Applaudissements]
alors là dit vous êtes là pour les
pièces jaunes
eh bien ça va être l'occasion pour vous
de gagner des pièces jaunes
voilà je le dis de faire gagner des
pièces jaunes la production voilà on va
donner voilà de l'argent pour les pièces
jaunes c'est très simple vous allez
devoir faire trois combats il y aura un
premier combat alors c'était et nora qui
était prévu mais après re a priori et
nora ne peut pas puisqu'elle est un
petit peu souffrante elle a une luxation
donc et nora ne le fera pas donc on va
changer c'est celui ou celle qui a le
même gabarit kenora c'est plus thierry
moreau dont thierry moreau david vous
allez avoir dix secondes pour mettre par
terre thierry moreau 15 secondes pour
mettre par terre te fans autres dj et le
temps vous voudrez on va dire 20
secondes aller pour m mokhtar par terre
il y aura 50 euros pour thierry mot 100
euros pour te fasses 150 euros pour
mokhtar et à chaque fois bien sûr que
vous les mettrez par terre on donnera
donc les l'argent pour les pièces jaunes
veulent avec moi la vidéo
ah oui alors donc thierry moreau est là
donc ils en train de se faire allez-y
bas venez thierry moreau donc 50 euros
il va se mettre donc sur le tatami
est-ce qu'on peut équiper s'il vous
plaît david douillet est ce qu'on peut
mettre david douillet ce qu'on peut lui
mettre également le team au no mercy
très vite les chiffres
merci
la haye alors qu'est ce qui se passe
entre les deux n'a pas bien c'est
technique c'est tout mais c'est vrai oui
l'udps avait mis sa nouvelle ceinture
jaune vous ça veut dire renier sa
ceinture jaune c'est quoi c'est une cata
font tous renoncé début je vous confirme
or en humour et les ceintures jaunes
aussi aller à lyon peut en jeu donc mais
je n'aurai pas de lois c'est magnifique
alors allez-y donc on fait le salut
c'est comme ça c'est quoi le salue comme
on dit il est d'accord faites-la nous
suit matin où je suis maman je viens vie
mais sa veste d'alarmé allez-y 10
secondes pour mettre par terre thierry
moreau sebha
[Applaudissements]
ça s'est fait régler merci merci
monsieur merci donc 50 au donc pour les
pièces et nocerino on rajoute 50 euros
bras votre chéri rajoute 50 euros
thierry moreau jaune c'est pas une pièce
jaune cette option 4 secondes maintenant
et regarder david douillet il remet même
le tatami alors attention cette femme
notre dj bleus
la tension est animé des coûts allaient
b
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît allez alors ah là là je
me parler de remettre le tatami il ya
100 euros alors attention maintenant 150
euros de pièces jaunes et on va appeler
mokhtar
[Applaudissements]
à
me déçoit pas si c'est pas lui qui va
taper et où je vais te mettre 100 après
les jeux le massacre bon il le fait
attention 150 ans
[Applaudissements]
pas sûr
bravo
[Applaudissements]
ce kit alors 150 serein quand 150 +50
donc ça va quand plus en plus sur 350
euros pour les pièces jaunes
bravo tu as bon alors david je retiens
deux choses de ces combats dix mois
alors la première chose eh bien j'ai un
poste pour vous ça vous dirait mais côté
ici et s'il ya une embrouille vous
intervenez termine avec l'usure c'est
fait donc ça c'est fait et deuxième est
david quand même c'est impressionnant
quand même en chantant 10-12 est
impressionnant mon père on a vu mokhtar
volée ça régresse qu est ce que le
réalisateur peut leur montrer la
séquence avec potard ce que mokhtar
c'est toi c'est quelqu'un que je joue
voilà que j'entraîne un petit peu quoi
le dos
non mon avis de dali
[Musique]